A POLITICAL EARTHQUAKE THAT
COULD HAVE MAJOR IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE MIDTERMS AND BEYOND.
40-POINT LANDSLIDE.
TRYING TO SPIN THE LOSS INTO A
WIN WITH HER EYES A NATIONAL
OFFICE.
>> THAT'S A DECISION I WILL MAKE
IN THE COMING MONTHS AND I WILL
NOT MAKE ANY ANNOUNCEMENTS THIS
EARLY BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'M THINKING ABOUT AND I'LL MAKE
A DECISION IN THE COMING MONTHS.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP GLOATING
OVER THE LOSS OF HIS MOST
POLITICAL FOES CAUSING HIM A
FOOL WHO SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
HERSELF.
LIZ CHENEY THROWING PUNCHES
RIGHT BACK HOPING TO KEEP
FIGHTING.
>> I BELIEVE THAT DONALD TRUMP
CONTINUES TO POSE A VERY GRAVE
THREAT AND RISK TO OUR REPUBLIC.
I'M ABSOLUTELY GOING TO CONTINUE
THE BATTLE AND I THINK IT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING I'VE EVER
BEEN INVOLVED WITH AND I THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING AND CHALLENGE
OUR FAITH MIKE NATION HAS READ
IT ON MY FACE IN RECENT HISTORY
ENABLE THE CIVIL WAR.
IT'S ONE THAT WE MUST WIN.
>> DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA BEING
CALLED OUT FOR MOURNING THE LOSS
OF LIZ CHENEY WHO WAS ONCE A
ENEMY OF THE LEFT.
>> DOES THIS POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS A MOMENT AS WE HAVE
SEEN AT ANY TIME SINCE THE
MIDDLE OF THE 19TH CENTURY AND
THE RUN UP TO THE CIVIL WAR.
>> 39% OF THE ELECTORATE.
THEY WANT TO REPLACE THE U.N.
GOVERNMENTS, THAT WANT TO THROW
AWAY AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> I RESPECT AND ARE MOSTLY THE
COMMITMENT.
THAT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
HOW EXTREME AND DEVOTED TO
DONALD TRUMP IT IS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF ELEMENTS TO
THE LOSS AND I WANT TO COME TO
YOU ABOUT SOMETHING THAT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE CLIP ABOUT LIZ
CHENEY'S COMMITMENT TO
DEMOCRACY.
>> Dana: I HAVE FAMILY IN
WYOMING AND I SERVED WITH LIZ
AND THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN
DICK CHENEY WAS PRESIDENT.
I'VE TAKEN MYSELF AS AN ANALYST
LOOKING AT THIS.
ONE THING WYOMING VOTERS ARE
HYPER CONCERNED ABOUT IS
WYOMING.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF TALK
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
THAT THAT WAS ONE THING SHE WAS
NOT FOCUSED ON.
IT WAS PERMEATING THE ENTIRE
ELECTORATE AND THEN YOU HAD THE
TRUMP, BUT STAYING BETWEEN THE
TWO OF THEM IS REALLY REAL.
I WOULD LOVE FOR EVERYBODY TO
GET ALONG AND THAT'S NOT THE
REAL WORLD, I COULD NEVER RUN
FOR OFFICE IF I CANNOT DO ALL
THE THINGS THAT -- I TAKES A LOT
OF GUTS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN WYOMING,
DEMOCRACY AND THERE WAS AN
ELECTION, THERE WAS A PRIMARY,
THERE WERE TWO DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO WINNING THE
PRIMARY AND THE ONLY QUESTION
REALLY WAS YOU GOING TO LOSE BY
30 OR 40 POINTS?
IT TURNED OUT TO BE 40.
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT CONSTITUENCY
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AND MAY BE
PREMATURE, BUT I UNDERSTAND EVER
BUT HE WANTS TO KEEP THE OPTIONS
OPEN FOR WHATEVER HAPPENS BUT I
FIND IT HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
THOSE MEDIA PEOPLE WE JUST
SHOWED ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
LOWER GOVERNMENT.
BY THEN, THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
PROBABLY A PRESIDENT TRUMP BY
THEN BECAUSE IF HE WINS THE
SECOND TERM AND WANTS TO RUN
AGAIN, IF SHE RUNS AFTER THAT,
THERE WON'T BE ANYBODY TO DO
THAT.
THE OTHER THING I WILL SAY IS
WYOMING IS A SPECIAL PLACE.
LOW POPULATION STATES, THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE MOVING IN.
YOU SEE JACKSON HOLE, THAT'S
WHERE ALL THE VOTES CAME FROM.
THE REST OF THE STATE IS NOT
JACKSON HOLE.
IT'S GOING TO BE AN EASY WIN IN
NOVEMBER AS SHE WILL BE THE NEXT
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
WYOMING.
>> ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HARRIET HICKMAN, A
NEVER TRUMPER AT THE START AND
THEN FOUND TRUMP CULTURE AND NOW
GOING TO BE THE NEW CONGRESSMAN
FROM WYOMING.
WHAT YOU THINK THE ELECTION WAS
REALLY ABOUT?
DID SHE WIN OR LIZ CHENEY?
>> I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS -- I RAN FOR
OFFICE FIVE TIMES, CHENEY GOT
CLOBBERED.
SHE GOT CLOBBERED TO CLOBBERED.
WYOMING SAID I DON'T WANT ANY
PART OF HER, YOUR AGENDA, AND
REMEMBER SHE OUTRANKED HIM.
SHE HAD A LOT OF MONEY, SUPPORT,
HE ONLY WON BACK ONCE TWICE
BEFORE THAT.
HE IN FACT HAD WORKED WITH
CHENEY.
BUT THE TRUTH IS CHENEY LOST AND
I THINK IT'S VERY INTERESTING
THAT SHE WOULD ACTUALLY THINK
THAT SHE HAS A CHANCE AS A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE BECAUSE
THEY CAN BLOW SMOKE ALL OVER HER
AND TELL HER HOW WONDERFUL SHE
IS RIGHT NOW AND WHERE IT SHOULD
BE.
BUT IF YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO SUPPORT LIZ CHENEY,
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THEY USED HER
FOR THEIR OWN AGENDA, THEY USED
HER TO TROUNCE TRUMP, AND TRUMP
IS JUST WINNING ACROSS THE BOARD
IN THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A FUTURE
FOR LIZ CHENEY.
WHEN YOU DON'T WORK FOR THIS FOE
CONSTITUENCY WORK FOR, BUT
YOU'RE THERE FOR SOME HIGHER
POLITICAL AGENDA, THEN YOU'RE
NOT REALLY A PUBLIC SERVANT.
IDEOLOGIST.
>> GREG, THE JUDGE'S POINT ABOUT
WHO SHE WOULD REPRESENT A NO
EVERYBODY LOVES THE PHRASE.
AS A DEMOCRAT, I WOULD NOT VOTE
FOR LIZ CHENEY.
I WOULDN'T VOTE FOR ANDREW YANG,
THEY WOULD BE THIRD PARTY AND
THEN PROBABLY GET MORE
INDEPENDENT AND CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRATS KILLED OFF.
WHAT DO YOU THINK -- I KNOW YOU
HAVE THINGS YOU WANT TO SAY, BUT
START WITH AT LEAST THE IMPACT
OF THIS TRUMP ENDORSEMENT AND
WHAT YOU THINK I CARRY OVER INTO
THE MIDTERMS WILL BE.
>> OKAY.
SHE COMPARED THIS TO THE
CIVIL WAR.
SHE'S NUTS.
OKAY?
SHE'S OVERTAKING WITH SUCH
OBSESSION AND SUCH EMOTIONAL
BITTERNESS THAT SHE HAS THIS
GRANDIOSE VIEW OF HERSELF AND
IT'S ACTUALLY NOW GETTING
EMBARRASSING.
IT'S EMBARRASSING FOR HER.
I WISH HE HAD A FRIEND THAT
COULD TAKE HER SIDE SAYING
YOU'VE GOT TO CALM DOWN.
DON'T RUN FOR OFFICE, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET A NATIONAL OFFICE,
I GET YOUR GOING TO GET OFFICE
DEPOT.
REPUBLICANS HATE YOU, DEMOCRATS
DON'T WANT YOU, IT'S ALL DRIVEN
BY EMOTIONAL BROKENNESS THAT
HAVE BEEN FROM TRUMP.
SHE GOES BACK TO THE CIVIL WAR
AND OF COURSE SHE DIDN'T MENTION
THE IRAQ WAR OR THE AFGHANISTAN
WAR, BECAUSE IT CUTS A LITTLE
BIT TOO CLOSE TO HOME.
AND THEN SHE COMPARES HERSELF TO
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
PEOPLE SAY THAT TRUMP HAS AN
EGO, BUT WHEN HE SETS UP LIKE
THAT IT'S USUALLY WITH A WINK
AND EVERYBODY'S LAUGHING,
THERE'S NOTHING IN HER EYE BUT
SPEIGHTS.
IT'S SUCH A PERSONAL VENDETTA
FROM DAY ONE TREND.
TRUMP HA NO USE FOR THE CHENEY'S
BUT THE PARTY MOVED ON FROM THE
SORT OF THING.
SHE HASN'T.
THE STRUGGLES FOR THE CIVIL WAR
AND WE ARE TOLD DEMOCRACY, TRUMP
BORDERS ARE EVIL, TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE EVIL AND FIGHTING
EVIL.
HOW IS THAT -- HOW IS THAT NOT
INCITEMENT?
YOU CAN SMEAR MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE ORANGE HITLER, RIGHT?
I GUESS SHE HAS SOMETHING IN
COMMON WITH ABE LINCOLN AND THEY
BOTH ALLOW THEATER TO KILL THEM
AND HER THEATER WAS JANUARY 6TH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S GOING TO
DO NEXT, BUT I WOULD CONSIDER
TAKING A BREAK AND NOT LISTEN TO
DEMOCRATS, MEDIA, THEY WILL JUST
USE YOU.
SHE STARTED HER OWN PACK WHICH
IS HILARIOUS BUT NORMAL PEOPLE
DON'T GET THAT EMOTIONAL OVER
THIS STUFF.
I THINK SHE NEEDS -- SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO PULL HER BACK AND GO,
LOOK, EVERYBODY MOVED ON EXCEPT
FOR YOU.
IT'S TIME.
MAYBE SHE'S LISTENING TO ME AND
I CAN BE HER FRIEND.
>> THE NEW TOP ADVISOR.
>> I CAN BE PART OF HER PACK.
>> SEAN, QUICKLY ON THE MOST
CRITICAL ISSUE IN THE CAMPAIGN
WHICH WAS ELECTION DAY NIHILISM,
THE BIG LIE, AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AHEAD TO THE MIDTERMS.
TWO-THIRDS OF THE G.O.P.
NOMINEES THAT MADE IT TO THE
PRIMARIES DENIED THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN LEGITIMATELY WON
THE ELECTION.
>> I THINK WE LOOK AT THE RACE
AND IT GOES TO A POINT THAT DANA
MADE IT.
IT'S ABOUT WYOMING, RIGHT?
DICK CHENEY CAME OUT WITH AN AD
AND IT WAS ALL ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
HE SAID NOTHING ABOUT WYOMING SO
IF YOU'RE GOING TO RUN, YOU WANT
TO MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER.
HOW DO I MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER
BUT INFLATION IS RAGING IN A
RURAL AREA IN WISCONSIN.
GAS PRICES RUSH PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
IF SHE DID NOTHING TO FIGHT FOR
THOSE ISSUES.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE CHARISMA IF
YOU RUN FOR HIGHER OFFICE, SHE
HAS NO CHARISMA.
SHE'S SMART, BUT SHE'S GOING
NOWHERE.
SHE'S RUNNING FOR DOG CATCHER,
BUT NOT PRESIDENT.
TALK ABOUT THE THREATS TO THE
COMPANY, SORRY, YOU MAY NOT LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, YES, GENERATE SIX
HAPPENED, BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
POLITICIZING THE DOJ, WE'VE GOT
TEN TERRORISTS THAT CAME ACROSS
THE BORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO SPIN OURSELVES
INTO OBLIVION, THOSE ARE ISSUES
THAT AFFECT FAMILIES AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DRIVING AND THEY
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED AND TO SAY
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS THE
PROBLEM, I THINK SHE'S -- TO
YOUR POINT, DEMOCRATS
DETERMINATION TO DRIVE A
NARRATIVE ON DONALD TRUMP.
THINK OF JOHN McCAIN, THEY
LOVED HIM TOO.
ONCE JOHN McCAIN RAN FOR
PRESIDENT, THEY THREW HIM OUT
AND ATTACKED HIM!
WHERE WAS THE MEDIA SAYING
JOE MANCHIN -- WE LOVE
JOE MANCHIN SUPPORTING
DEMOCRACY.
HE START UP THE DEMOCRATS BUT OH
GOSH, WE'VE GOT A REPUBLICAN AND
I WILL STAND UP TO OTHER
REPUBLICANS IN THERE FOR
DEMOCRACY, THEY'VE GOT COURAGE.
IT'S ALL GARBAGE.
>> COUPLE THINGS, THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT AND DULY NOTED YOU
DID NOT WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.